victory cs 5 years it is fundamentally important for you
that everyone come leader it
doesn’t matter at all this
is our holiday I think that for our
former allies in the anti
-Hitler coalition this is not
internal political and
morally right to come to us we are waiting and
will be glad if it doesn’t go  if not, it’s
their choice, but it seems to me for
and for them there was more of you there is a feeling
that we have at least this one no victory no such
feeling from it’s impossible to count enough,
but to understand this is narrow-minded
people who can’t read write
carry any garbage Europe breaks there
about the equal responsibility of
Hitler and Stalin, this is [ __ ],
just
about
you need to look at the chronology of
events beginning in 19-18, how it
all happened,
who and and what documents were signed with
Hitler, by the way, I’m Stalin, as it were,
to understand not to treat him as a tyrant there and
so on, but  he did not stain himself with direct
contacts with Hitler, and oh, there is not a single
signature of Stalin Hitler, but Hitler and
Prime Minister of Great Britain Hitler
Prime Minister of France there is Hitler and there is a
leader of Poland and he is with them and
they are with them Work with Hitler I have
repeatedly met the
Czechoslovaks of Poland together with Hitler
shared this numerical key and in fact
talked with them about the introduction of troops into
czechoslovakia the
only thing that the germans told them hitler
said just not on the same day with us we
won’t interfere with each other we don’t
pretend that it will come to what you
claim for the tishinskaya region it’s a
direct evil well just read everything in the
documents there i am here and zarchy  he understood
it all looked at emphasized something they
heard, well, of course, it’s written there and
then they will tell it’s to blame,
so they’re to blame, starting from 38,
this Munich so-called from the mountains, but
it was the first step towards unleashing the Second
World War
more equates the Soviet  the union is
officially the usa with a difference in the sky the union of
hitler germany puts an
equal sign and accuses both countries of
unleashing  In the event of the Second World War, we would
immediately rush into nowhere, we would not rush anywhere, the
secret protocols of
Molotov Ribbentrop condemned Russia will do
[music],
but then let other
countries honestly say how they assess the
behavior of their leadership in those
days, let them say honestly about it, they
won’t come
fictitious sazhens far-fetched accusations
or claims
talk about the past I’m talking about today everything
no don’t look at today’s authorities the
manager didn’t call you at your
expense they didn’t call you and you don’t have to go
there but went for the fishing lines the
camera also tells the Ukrainian front about the
100th wax
division, we understand  that this is nonsense, we
understand that all this is the conjuncture of
today, and millions of Ukrainians
who fought against Hitler fought against
Nazism somewhere a spit in their face, I
assure you they are afraid, just their mouths are open, but
because the persecution will begin immediately,
I know what is happening in their hearts  for people
who fought against Nazism with weapons in
their hands, for them this spit
means n  about the current president, ukraine
wants to be so good-looking for the
current leadership of poland,
which, in my opinion, is making a very
big mistake,
how do you feel about the legs when
we can repeat
which rod that on may 9 on a bmw
or a mercedes
from behind we can repeat to berlin
listen thank you  grandfather for the victory
thanks to grandfather for the victory excellent and we can
repeat
you know that this can be interpreted
in different ways the Soviet Union was subjected to a
very terrible terrible
unforgivable attack by Nazi
Germany we lost 27 million
people there is not a single country in the world that
would suffer such such such such  morning, and
if someone dares to do
something like that, we will repeat the study of
women, of course, we have never aspired to this
and are not going to strive,
and the Russian leadership never
raises the question in this way if the
lie about which you said to consider
it with  such positions,
it is enough to recall Alexander
Nevsky then come to us with a sword from the sword
and die
[music]